vous avec alexandre kateb économiste et
spécialiste des économies émergentes
bonsoir alexandre kateb merci d'être
avec nous on dirait sur rt france une
réunion a eu donc lui aujourd'hui entre
les principaux pays producteurs de
pétrole et leurs partenaires donc que
boîte on retenir de cette réunion cette
réunion aux fêtes était attendue par
tous les participants je crois assez
fait sous la pression des états unis qui
ont intérêt à ce que les prix ne chute
pas en deçà des niveaux actuels et
également de l'arabie saoudite qui en
fait on l a déclenché cette guerre des
prix et à inonder le marché avec une
offre supplémentaire ne s'attendait pas
du tout à ce que les prix chutent en
raison de la crise du port aux navires
us et que on se retrouve aujourd hui
dans une situation où il n'y a quasiment
pas de capacité de stockage et je sais
ce que craignent et tous les
participants à cette réunion c'est qu'à
un moment donné en fin de compte le prix
du pétrole a et jusqu'à 0 voire soient
négatifs parce qu'en fait les
producteurs devront quelque part payer
pour que le pétrole soit ils ont
ponctionné quoi alors quelques coins ans
quel est le point d'achoppement dans ces
négociations
le point d'achoppement principal c'est
qu'on fait les participants n'ont pas du
tout la même notion sur l'idée de
réduction des capacités est ce que cela
implique pour les états unis il ya déjà
une réduction de capacités naturelles
sur le marché qui est liée à la chute de
la demande de l'ordre de 25 à 30%
aujourd'hui sur le marché intérieur
américain et donc les américains disent
que de toutes les manières ils vont
réduire leurs capacités de production
mais les russes disent non nous ne
voulons pas de cette réduction spontanée
nous voulons des objectifs fixés par
l'état qui soit contraignant et que tout
le monde respecte ses objectifs pour
pouvoir évaluer en fait justement le
respect de l'accord
qui sera à prix sinon ça n'a pas là
d'effectivité quelles conséquences sur
le consommateur sur les consommateurs
que nous sommes de cette situation de
mésentente entre ces différents pays
en temps normal disons que quand le prix
du pétrole chutent les consommateurs
devraient plutôt se réjouir
sauf que là on situ situation de
confinement et même si on va sortir du
confinement de manière très graduelle en
fin de compte les déplacements ne vont
pas reprendre très fortement et donc les
consommateurs ne tire pas vraiment
avantage de cette situation et sa des
répercussions sur la confiance en fait
économique parce que le pétrole est
souvent un indicateur de la de la
croissance et donc des prix très bas
voire des prix qui pourrait atteindre 10
dollars le baril indiquerait un
effondrement total de l'économie
mondiale et donc dans ce cas de figure
les consommateurs seraient aussi
impactées par cette perte générale de
confiance alors l'objectif effectivement
être une coupe commune de 10 à 15
millions de barils par jour c'est ce
qu'a confirmé le ministre koweïtien du
pétrole
est-ce que ça me paraît possible
c'est possible si vraiment il ya un
effort qui est fait par tous les pays
participants pour disons faire des
sacrifices et et réduire dans des
proportions substantielle leurs propres
productions
ça veut dire que les états unis le
canada doit aussi y participer
et il faut aussi que les pays
consommateurs quelque part participent à
cet effort notamment à travers leurs
stocks stratégiques qu'ils doivent
remplir et qu'ils doivent actionner pour
fonctionner une partie de cette offre
excédentaire qui est sur le marché
aujourd'hui
merci là où alexandre kateb économiste
spécialiste des économies émergentes
d'avoir été avec nous